- It's like y'all are members
of the coolest rock band ever.
Like yeah.
- I love your outfit.
- Thank you, I love yours.
- Very patriotic.
You're a patriotic rock band.
It's so nice to see you again.
Oh, you smell good.
- Thank you, it's essential oils.
- Oh my god.
- Peppering, lavender.
- Yeah, I do feel like I'm in a spa.
- Yeah, that's what I
try to walk around with.
- Yes, I like that.
That's very peaceful.
Have y'all ever met before?
- No.
- I know your work.
- And notably I didn't
get the smell compliment
so it must be real.
(laughing)
- [Folake] On both of our behalf.
- I don't smell.
I just smell I guess like oh day Me.
- So nice to meet you.
- Oh my god, so gifted.
She's like crazy talented.
So, wait, I have to talk about this first.
I hear you just had an
incredible birthday party.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I wanna talk about it.
Like 'cause you love dancing.
- I love dancing.
- Me too.
- [Folake] You do?
- Yes.
- You have to come to
the next Naija Sweat.
- Okay, I love dancing.
- Okay.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, 'cause
that's what my party was about.
There we go.
(audience clapping)
Yeah man, Nigerians we party.
- I love that.
So you had also a big Nigerian wedding
on Bob Hearts Abishola
that last season, right?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] What was that experience like?
- You know my mom was a
party planner in Nigeria.
- [Kelly] It's beautiful.
- Yes, bride's maids as well.
My mom was a party planner in Nigeria
so as soon as I walked into
that room it took me back.
'Cause we used to help her set up.
It was brilliantly done.
We got nominated for an Emmy.
The production team is amazing.
The art department was amazing.
- It is and ours is as well.
It's so funny how people always see us,
but the people behind the scenes
like making everything happen.
- I think they're the hardest
working people in showbiz.
The crew, for sure.
- And how they create things.
And then also it must have been nice
that it did ring true for you.
Like what it was like at home.
- Yeah, it was very authentic.
- [Kelly] It's respectful.
- Yeah.
- So what can people
expect in season four?
- Season four.
Well now Bob and Abishola are married
and they're settling into marriage life,
something I know nothing about.
And I find that once you're settled
into the comfort of marriage,
you can now go exploring other things.
- What would your dream role be?
And I'm gonna tell you what I feel like
your dream role should be.
- Tell me.
- When you came out here
the first time we met
I was like my God,
so is she promoting some kind of movie
where you play a god or a superhero?
Because you look.
- I like the sound of that.
- 'Cause you look like just someone who,
you just embody power
and your presence is
like so powerful to me.
I love it.
I think you should do that.
- I mean yeah.
Look, I got into show business,
I got into music and acting
'cause I like fantastical epic adventures.
And I also studied Israeli martial arts.
- Krav Maga?
- Yeah Krav Maga.
- She's deadly.
- I am.
When I started learning it
I was so frightened I
was gonna hurt someone.
I became so timid.
Yeah, 'cause I didn't want to hurt anyone,
but it's pretty intense.
So I want to kick ass and go on adventure.
- Yeah, see I'm right.
You should do that.
Like action movies.
I feel like you're the
person that would be like
I don't need a stunt double.
Like, you're like, "I got this."
You would wanna do it?
- Oh yeah, oh yeah.
I was in Miami last week on para sailing.
- I've always wanted to do that.
Is it scary?
- It's so peaceful.
No, it's very peaceful.
And then over the summer I
was in Kenya hot ballooning.
And then I went trekking with
mountain gorillas in Rwanda.
Yeah, with the Diane Fosse Foundation.
Oh, that's incredible.
- I have a couple friends
that have done that
and they said it was the
most magical experience.
Yes, magical.
- You would do this definitely.
- [Allison] I have done it.
- Oh, you have?
- Yes, yes.
Yeah, it was the most magical thing.
It's hard to describe, in Rwanda.
- [Folake] Oh, nice.
- Wow.
- [Folake] They fart a lot.
- They fart a lot?
- Very loud.
- Wow, you went close.
I wasn't that close.
- They fart and then
they scratch their belly
and look at you like, what's up?
(laughing)
- It's like a man in your house.
You just described living with the dude.
So wait, so I know that you just released
your first music video because
I saw it and I love it.
It's so cool.
- [Folake] You watched it?
I did, I love even the hero angle
with like the fire going
on in the background.
The hook is so incredibly cool.
♪ Ehen, ehen ♪
♪ Okay, okay ♪
Yeah, it's so incredibly cool.
I love the storytelling.
I love like the live shots.
It looks almost like newsfeed.
- It is, so unfortunately in 2020
there was a shooting during a protest
and a bunch of innocent
protestors were murdered.
And it's questionable who
actually committed those murders
but it's said that it
was officials of Nigeria.
So this song Ehen, ehen, okay, okay,
I shot it in Nigeria entirely.
And I have clips from the
actual protest in there
and I just wanted to
highlight that that happened.
- It looked like that,
it appeared like that, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Ehen, ehen, okay, okay.
You have to say with an accent.
- I know, okay, okay.
I can't, I'm gonna fail you every time.
At least I'm consistent.
I love when you come on though.
You're just such a
rockstar as you walk out.
I love that you're both in
some kind of rock band today.